all right so today's topic the michael
jackson
leaving neverland documentary now since
it came out i've been kind of hesitant
to cover it because i've been just kind
of
watching it from afar personally i'm not
a mj fan
are you yeah all right now when it came
to bill cosby i was with you all right
when it came to r kelly i was also not
saying boat condemned them right away
with this one y'all kind of lost me and
i'll give you guys a couple reasons
why okay seven quick facts uh that i
thought were pretty interesting uh
safe truck claims that he was raped uh
and sexually assaulted numerous times
in the upstairs of the train station uh
safe chuck was with michael between 1988
and 1992 until he was 14. the strain
station where he claimed to have sex
was only built in 1994. there's a two
year discrepancy
number two safe chuck claimed that he
married michael jackson you remember the
rings it was a really weird scene
right and for their honeymoon they went
to euro disney in 1988.
euro disney wasn't built until 1992. i
danced when i heard that he died i was
laying in bed the news came on i got out
of bed and i was oh
thank god he can't hurt any more
children
her son in a deposition in court under
oath said that he didn't realize he was
abused
until he went through therapy in 2013
and he had never admitted to anyone
before that
wade claims that this is all about
getting the truth out there
and his original lawsuit wade said he
would keep silence about the allegations
if he was paid
and compensated that they would seal
this whole thing at the end of the
documentary do you remember
when they're burning michael jackson's
memorabilia yeah way to robson
went to an auction house and started
selling out michael jackson's
memorabilia for hundreds of thousands of
dollars
and he asked the auction house to do it
anonymously so he wouldn't be named
and the auction house refused and made
it public so i think it's very
very ironic that on one hand you were
selling the profitable stuff
trying to do it anonymously on the other
here you are burning his other
memorabilia at the end of the
documentary
to me you burning the stuff that you
couldn't sell
isn't powerful it's opportunistic and
here's the last one
wade robson in the documentary claims
that during a dinner
michael jackson's neverland ranch he saw
how decrepit michael was
this was uh shortly before the trial was
about to begin yeah when wait saw how
bad michael was doing at this
family dinner he decided that he was
going to testify in order to help
michael because he loved the man even
though he had abused him
problem is that dinner happened after
the court case
and this is corroborated by other people
that were at that dinner
because wade claims he was never invited
at the ranch before then for a dinner
for years
so how could a dinner that happened
after the court case
motivates you to testify in the court
case that happened before
here's another thing when you reach that
level of fame lawsuits become
very very common i get sued
probably 15 times a year i have
lawyers on a monthly retainer just
because
you get sued so much when you're when
you're famous
denver singer-songwriter crystal cartier
is suing jackson claiming she wrote
dangerous in 1985.
i believe i am annie from smooth
criminal
ah i can't wait today to get to that
level where i get sued
i can't wait to get to that level when i
get spooked with 50 a year and i don't
even
uh what well i don't know talk to my
lawyers i don't know
now like putting this [ __ ] in
perspective i'll understand
yeah you gotta be productive he's he was
a billion dollar man
he was making so much money off of his
catalog and his tour that he didn't have
time to focus on this stuff
here's another problem you know like
wade as an adult testified for michael
jackson he was the star witness for
michael jackson's defense
twice once as a kid as an adult as a
grown man okay still twice
but here's my thing here's my big
problem with it okay not only did he lie
about the dinner that
supposedly encouraged him to testify not
only that
but when you put your star witness you
need someone who you know is ironclad
that has no risk of faltering
when they're being you know
cross-examined by the prosecutors
if i was a serial cheater all right i
cheated on all my girlfriends
and they were coming to me and in this
hypothetical world cheating was a big
crime okay
and now i'm put on the stand and people
are like who's gonna be your start
witness you know which one of my
girlfriends
i'm not gonna ask to be on the witness
stand for me
the girlfriend i know i cheated on wanna
know why
because she might break and if she
breaks i am
[ __ ] finished so why would michael
jackson's defense team
ask for wade robson to be on the if they
suspected even for a second
that weight had been abused why would
michael allow it if he knew he had
abused
wait there were so many witnesses that
they could choose from they didn't need
weight
wade volunteered he was so enthusiastic
and then they went and they examined him
they did so much witness prep
they had investigators to look into his
backstory to make sure he's ironclad
that's when they decided he could be the
star witness right
safe chuck claims that what michael
approached him to testify in the 2005
trial he begged him he begged him
and then safe strike said no i'm done
with you i'm off just leave me alone
there's no reason michael jackson would
ever approach say chuck to testify
because safe chuck was barred from
testifying
as per the judge he was a non-factor a
non-entity he couldn't take the witness
down
so why wouldn't michael jackson beg him
to testify if he can't test him
saves up was never an issue during the
trial
we did no work on him we did no
preparation on him he was not an issue
he was never ever ever gonna testify the
court judge melville took him out of the
mix
long before the trial started okay
and this is the last one wade robson had
burnt a lot of bridges
okay because he was dating michael
jackson's at the time
and then he cheated on her to sleep with
britney spears who at the time was
dating justin timberlake
would knit up breaking up their
relationship
that's about him right he ended up
getting blackballed from a lot of places
because it wasn't just
britney spears and justin timberlake he
was getting blackballed from their
managers their whole production
companies all their producers
as well as everyone on the justin
timberlake side because he has weird
ways of working
yes and then you've done this with a lot
of other artists in hollywood so he was
seen as someone who's opportunistic who
couldn't be trusted he was getting
blackballed he kept latching on to
michael in order to get more work and
michael being gracious kept helping
him you know it's like people say oh
michael's a predator this and that
wade and his family chased michael for
years trying to hound them so that they
could get weighed in contact with
michael
after he left australia his mother
admits this in a documentary
i hounded michael i sent him letters we
visited la we went outside the ranch we
were just hoping that michael would talk
to him she was had it
yo they are opportunistic people that's
proven in their behavior but
i thought there was one part that was
interesting which i don't think is
concrete per se but it is interesting
it's interesting because because a note
was found
um and confirmed to be written by wade
that stated this and i quote
my story of abuse and its effects will
make me relatable
slash relevant right the last sentence
of that note
said it's time for me to get mine when
questioned and asked what he meant by
that last sentence he said he didn't
know and he didn't remember
now is that conclusive evidence no
is it suspicious considering everything
else we know about weight
yeah and i think that's my entire
problem with this
but before i go on to like my real
thoughts about this i just want to
disprove a couple of things well there's
a rumor that they say
they found child pornography during the
fbi race they did they did they did not
okay if you find child pornography at
anyone's place they're getting charged
second thing there's a boy who could
draw his penis and they have that in
that position
they could i mean i could drive penis
when i was a kid michael jackson's penis
so the boy claimed he could they got the
boy to draw a sketch with another sketch
artist they got involved
then he went for jackson's place they
made him get naked yeah they did
they made they took embarrassing photos
of michael with naked of his private
plugs
and then they compared it to the sketch
and they did not come
close to matching so that is again
another lie
they made a little boy do i penis
it's not funny but it's pretty much
money that's [ __ ] funny why did he
pay 20 million
first he didn't pay 20 million dollars
his insurance company did all right
that's the first but that's not him no
his insurance companies not him it's
like you get a car accident
because if you get in a car accident
right and then you have to pay
the other person's you know surgery all
this stuff
who does that is it you or your
insurance company interested me
okay that's one two there were two court
cases happening at that time there was a
civil and a criminal court okay okay
both happening about the same incident
the difference is one is in regards to
jail time
and one is in regards to monetary gain
the problem is
that the court system the way it worked
in california at the time which has been
changed today
is that the civil case was happening
before the criminal case
which meant that michael and his defense
would have to show
what their defense is in the civil case
before the criminal case which gave the
prosecutors time to prepare
for their defense and so mj's team
really didn't want them to see their
defense before it started now they
didn't want to pay the money either
so they asked the judge please move the
civil case we'll defend it after the
criminal one
but not before because it'll cause us
problems the judge refused
even though it's a very reasonable
request the judge repeatedly refused
so they kept trying to last minute when
they realized they couldn't they said
you know what let's just pay this off
and then we can focus on the criminal
case because that's what really matters
so that's what they did now you paying
people off is not an admission of guilt
in fact in the settlement money there is
no admission of guilt
they clearly state that this is not an
admission of guilt
they just move that out of the way so
they can focus on the one that really
matters
which is the criminal case in the
justice system it takes a lot of money
takes a lot of time
it's a lot so sometimes it is actually
worth it
for you to even if you didn't do [ __ ] hi
rich was michael giraffe money rich bruv
he was worth billions and
billions of dollars i said giraffe money
rich i don't know what that means means
you have giraffes in your backyard and
you're able to feed them okay [ __ ]
alright
chill out like just having a dog is
expensive giraffe money that's true
you know how expensive it is to have a
hamster and bring that [ __ ] to the vet
imagine a giraffe
giraffe how much how much drunk do you
think
yeah it takes to set a giraffe
he got giraffe he got giraffe money and
so because of that fact
monkey money he said it was better for
me to just pay this small sum he didn't
even though he didn't want to and he
regrets it to this day
he said let me just pay so i can focus
on the criminal case exactly because i
need to get back on tour
reasons people think he's guilty the two
biggest ones are
everyone agrees on this michael jackson
liked hanging around kids
yes the family doesn't deny the
opposition doesn't die everyone knows
that yeah and people see a grown adult
man
hanging around kids and they're like
what the [ __ ] wrong with you but the
two things you have to understand is
michael never had a childhood never my
uncle didn't have that childhood and
he would always ask us you know what is
it like to have birthday parties or what
is it like to just hang out with your
friends
and simple stuff like that he just
didn't have and he would kind of live
vicariously through us with that
he couldn't even go to the mall or to go
to a movie without closing the whole
movie down
that's a different life than anyone else
you know has
and two the grass is always greener on
the other side meaning when you were a
child you always thought damn i can't
wait to be an adult
it's going to be great i'm going to have
all this [ __ ] i'm going to take care of
things drive my car knows i'm going to
tell you what to do then you get to be
an adult
damn i want to be a kid again but you
don't go back because that's your past
where's michael no because you ain't got
that money true if you had listen
imagine i give you giraffe money how
much time would you spend in bed
watching manga how many mango would you
no
i would not you know what i would do i
would pay the [ __ ] who writes the
mangosteen give me that [ __ ] exclusively
so i can sit at home and be like 30
editions that no one's ever read [ __ ]
and giraffe money okay giraffe money so
if you have giraffe money
you will go back into childhood i will
buy myself
a flamethrower and the biggest super
soaker you've ever seen
we're teams we use the whole ranch
my favorite thing in the world play if
you call it a sports sport it's a water
balloon fight
because i like the way they splatter
when they hit
i've never lost a water balloon fight
i'm the michael jordan of water balloon
[Music]
i dried up they pushed me right back in
i can't believe that first shot of me
with no shirt on
i'm a nice person i just took her
and i
[Music]
okay here we go in three wait i can wait
wait don't cheat ready
this [ __ ] really said don't cheat no
cheat
this [ __ ] got giraffe money but
he's concerned about this kid cheating
in a slide race giraffe money
no but your hands got to be inside the
pocket man no no no no no
i'm going to beat you are you ready wait
no no i'm not ready
ready no i'm crazy okay no you got to
stretch it
back you got it whoa whoa i'm doing i'm
not doing the superman
ready good job you cheated
wow he cheats a lot
if you close your eyes and listen to
them you can't tell no they're kids
they're kids this man literally said my
favorite sport
is water balloon fight i don't disagree
you ever had a water balloon fight but
what you ever had
i'm not mad but that's something i would
have said when i was seven [ __ ]
do you mean as a grown man we don't
think about things like that but that's
what i'm saying when i say his reality
is different but if you have giraffe
money
he could have bought a team
he literally he could have created a
league straight up
it's a different reality but then again
you know it doesn't brew or disprove
anything
you cannot disprove something that
didn't happen if i say you raped me how
are you gonna prove that you didn't do
it
so my problem with this i felt like the
documentary was unbalanced
there were some creepy photos that they
used michael touched me and then you saw
michael in bed like this
yes and i'm like yo listen that is such
a bad photo
it would be like it'd be like i mean
abba hates kids
the document starts off they do this a
very deceptive thing where they start
off with giving you a bunch of facts
michael came to this stand we have
pictures of this we have all this
evidence of him talking to my kids and
we had a great time right so they set up
the whole first half where they're just
doing all these beautiful things
right and then the moment it gets to
abuse everything turns into conjecture
none of it's provable there are no facts
no there are no way no
there are no corroborations and my
problem is you know
when this documentary was going to come
out they didn't even allow the jackson
family to respond
which they wanted to do on camera okay
and even more egregious at that
they didn't even interview the other
kids that they claimed in the
documentary
were going to were abused which is super
egregious because they didn't even
tell those kids that their names were
going to be referenced [ __ ] up so
that's why
brett barnes is suing the documentary
because like you never told me this and
i was never abused so why are you
claiming that
right dan reed the guy who created the
document he says
i didn't want to interview them because
it would undermine the documentary
because they have a financial motive to
live for michael jackson and i'm like
wait
wait robson don't have a final financial
motive yeah but he's not paid for the
documentary abba
and the other boys that were abused
isn't it in their financial interest
to be aligned with safe chuck yeah and
wade robson yeah how come they were not
interviewed
because it doesn't fall in line with
your narrative nah man that [ __ ] was
just
bad right now we live in an era of to
believe the victim because victims
oftentimes have gone you know not
believed in all this stuff
we have gone to the other extreme where
we believe all the time and it results
in people like jesse smoke
right who lie for personal gain and tell
these outlandish nerves right that was
hey that was that was
that was that's real that was that was
real do you know how many black men have
gone to jail because a white woman
claimed that she was raped
emmett till did we forget these stories
that people lie for more frivolous
things that we could imagine because
their honor was stained
so who wouldn't lie for 20 million
dollars enough money to change
legacies i'm not going to go on the
other side saying like yeah you push
positionally did not do it and stuff
like that i'm not even gonna go there
i'm gonna be neutral about this thing
i don't know if he did i don't know if
he did not but what i have up to now
i can't be like yeah he did no i can't
condemn him i can't stop listening to
his music and i can't just pull this
music oh
wait i can't do that because we don't
have proof and the only proof that we
have
is people that were lying you know stop
sign let's change
their stories that's not a proof i want
us to curl tail it back
because it isn't by locking up people
who are potentially innocent
that we are righting the wrongs of the
world the burden of proof is high
because it's better
for 10 guilty men to go free than for
one innocent man to suffer
and now we're turning what may be
someone who just loved children
who loved alleviating their stress who
was a philanthropist
on a level we had never seen from a
major artist who
just focused on the suffering of kids so
much because
at neverland he brought in thousands of
kids terminally ill
sick kids orphans people with their
families he brought them out of his own
volition to give him a day of joy and
have fun and celebrate
and that to me sad that someone who may
have loved and wanted to protect
children his entire life
may now have his legacy be the complete
opposite
because of a of over correction
[Music]